Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we're going to talk about explosions.
To be more precise, imagine that we already
have the physics simulation data for an explosion
on our computer, but we would like to visualize
it on our screen.
This requires a light simulation program that
is able to create an image of this virtual
scene that looks exactly the same as it would
in reality.
We have had plenty of earlier episodes on
light transport, and as you know all too well,
it is one of my favorite topics.
I just can't get enough of it.
I've put a link to these related episodes
in the video description.
If we wish to render a huge smoke plume, we
perform something that computer graphics people
call volumetric light transport.
This means that a ray of light doesn't necessarily
bounce off of the surface of materials, but
it can penetrate their surfaces and scatter
around inside of them.
A technique that can deal with this is called
volumetric path tracing, and if we wish to
create an image of an explosion using that,
well, better pack some fast food because it
is likely going to take several hours.
The explosion in this image took 13 hours
and it is still not rendered perfectly.
But this technique is able to solve this problem
in 20 minutes, which is almost 40 times quicker.
Unbelievable.
The key idea is that this super complicated
volumetric explosion data can be reimagined
as a large batch of point light sources.
If we solve this light transport problem between
these point light sources, we get a solution
that is remarkably similar to the original
solution with path tracing, however, solving
this new representation is much simpler.
But that's only the first step.
If we have a bunch of light sources, we can
create a grid structure around them, and in
these gridpoints, we can compute shadows and
illumination in a highly efficient manner.
What's more, we can create multiple of these
grid representations.
They all work on the very same data, but some
of them are finer, and some of them are significantly
sparser, more coarse.
Another smart observation here is that even
though sharp, high-frequency illumination
details need to be computed on this fine grid,
which takes quite a bit of computation time,
it is sufficient to solve the coarse, low-frequency
details on one of these sparser grids.
The results look indistinguishable from the
ground truth solutions, but the overall computation
time is significantly reduced.
The paper contains detailed comparisons against
other techniques as well.
Most of these scenes are rendered using hundreds
of thousands of these point light sources,
and as you can see, the results are unbelievable.
If you would like to learn even more about
light transport, I am holding a Master-level
course on this at the Vienna University of
Technology in Austria.
I thought that the teachings should not only
be available for those 30 people who sit in
the room, who can afford a university education.
It should be available for everyone.
So, we made the entirety of the lecture available
for everyone, free of charge, and I am so
glad to see that thousands of people have
watched it, and to this day I get many messages
that they enjoyed it and now they see the
world differently.
It was recorded live with the students in
the room, and it doesn't have the audio quality
of Two Minute Papers.
However, what it does well, is it conjures
up the atmosphere of these lectures and you
can almost feel like one of the students sitting
there.
If you're interested, have a look, the link
is available in the video description!
And make sure to read this paper too, it's
incredible.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!